el asesinato del dirigente de relaciones
internacionales de la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas de Ecuador
Eduardo mendúa ha generado reacciones no
solo en el país sino del propio
representante de los pueblos indígenas
de la ONU el presidente del foro
permanente de asuntos indígenas de la
ONU Darío Mejía Montalvo calificó el
asesinato como repudiable y altamente
preocupante exigió las autoridades
actuar con rapidez y castigar a los
responsables Eduardo mendúa fue
asesinado el 26 de febrero al estilo
sicariato según informó el ministro de
interior Juan Zapata cuando retornaba a
su vivienda la provincia de sucumbíos
por un grupo armado formaba parte de la
nacionalidad indígena cofaán que hace
vida en la amazonía ecuatoriana su más
reciente participación se produjo en la
asamblea nacional de la conae en la
ciudad de Quito donde los movimientos
indígenas le han exigido la renuncia al
cargo al presidente de la república
Guillermo lasso por una supuesta trama
de corrupción y narcotráfico que señalan
a su entorno más cercano sucede cuando
hace siete meses también su hermano
fuera asesinado a las organizaciones
indígenas desconfían de los pedidos de
con El Ejecutivo nacional y han
rechazado la presencia de la actividad
minera y petrolera en sus territorios
sin consulta previa los movimientos
indígenas de rechazan la militarización
en treinta nuevos pozos petroleros y 11
explotaciones mineras y aseguran que
tanto el presidente de la república como
la empresa petrolera Estatal tienen
cuotas de responsabilidad por la
militarización de sus territorios y
cuotas responsabilidad por la omisión de
la seguridad en sus zonas sucede en
medio de un clima de atención política
en medio de investigaciones el
presidente de la república los
movimientos indígenas anunciaron
previamente que radicalizarán la
vigilancia a sus territorios y harán una
nueva asamblea para evaluar lo sucedido
mientras la fiscalía anunció la
detención de un primer involucrado en el
asesinato